за моєю спиною у been in love
здоровий не будемо для парламенту
нідерландів тут за скільки ти
а не з і над буду розряду ти завгодно
про асоціацію з Україною
давайте точні прогнози поки що складно
багату будда заклади ти ж новому
кабінету міністрів нідерландів більше
зараз тут нідерландський сина тури
протерти шкіру
послуги провінції мати до датського
професію
а на засіданні їдьте дога разів над і
чекати за рахунок rhyme вчитель кит шваль
зарплат не
ми виручили до дна різних расп це ти
про асоціацію України чи євросоюзу сина
tour with провінції фрісландія тенгу
мишкою у скромному сільському пляшку-то
травня разом з дружиною робочий кабінет
аліною важлива віш і сина торгів
збирається голосувати за асоціацію з
україною
я вигляд початку позитивно стала вся duty та
біля води
україна дуже багато зру було для
асоціацій з цього жив його звучання іншого
багата чого в Україні до сильно на лого
джина
процес у роті по метод і алла україна та
без нас обізнаний з приводу багата роботи
думають вже добрий знаючи
ми ж можемо моєї в тему 3 етапом ах ти
сама сім'я та папайя навколо біля води
прошу частиною україни тієї з 3-го low
нідерландах у су-100
принесла уряду чий мало проблем
поспішаю прохолодно партія мало нейтральну
позицію ще до референдуму, а після
рішення на інше українство
прем'єр-міністр марк жовтець вино вся сука
ти виходу squeeze і
c стало однією з причин, ніж вона виборах
до нижньої палати парламенту його палець і
l'autre мало навісимо депутатських
мандатів менше ніш папороті разу
атомів на один голос менше квіткового
але потім переїхати кавуни тому що я
набагато вибору класна голосу рожевої
води через наші є опозиція щодо
істринському rev a random
нах на булочок і позиція нагадуючи
заявляла москва самара занесені
гідний вигляд так я пила горілку david r
кубі
виходити з України олег трубочок покази
і свої запитані на вибір ай та раз
побачив відразу видів свій голос
проєвропейські партії демократи 66
активно ритуалу за україну коридорів
оренду мам і тпр найму поверни шоу види в
урядова коаліція по ясно неаполі таких
чуму про референдум про сутність азію так і
у роті Петро і модель така
все шпрот асоціації вислужився менше
50 і сотні жителів нідерландів
значить але менше там у продовжать і
ратифікацію силоміць і логічно інакше
насичує одружуються їх злив за блатом been
in love a парламенту нідерландів
на ведені оптимісти викрав і а ліском
тчуть все буде добре